-Thanks to newly developed
technology here at "Late Night,"
we now have the ability to
record the tiny voice
that is inside
Donald Trump's head.
And you might
be surprised to know that,
like everyone's inner voice,
Donald Trump's
is filled with
paralyzing fear and self-doubt.
So, here it is once again,
the tiny voice in
the back of Donald Trump's head.
♪♪♪♪
-Hey, Donald.
It's the tiny voice
in the back of your head,
and it's time to
sign some documents
with your very large signature.
Okay, first, peek at
the other guys's papers,
like you did in middle school.
Okay, good peeking.
And now remember to do it
real big and real slow
to make everybody else wait.
That's what you call
a power move.
Okay. And now trade them.
Take one. Take another one.
Now you have two.
Justin has zero. Oh!
Whoa! Oh!
I liked when I had two.
Okay. Now look at it again.
This looks like something
you've seen before.
Oh, it's a copy of
what you just did.
Okay. Real big and real slow,
like a winner.
♪♪♪♪